ahora vamos a explorar una de las
reacciones más fundamentales en química
orgánica primero echemos un vistazo a lo
que haremos reaccionar de este lado
tenemos a la unión hidróxido y tiene una
carga negativa porque el oxígeno para
ser neutro tiene que tener 6 electrones
de valencia pero en este caso tiene 1 2
3 4 5 6 más un electrón de este enlace
que tiene con el hidrógeno ese electrón
extra le da la carga negativa -1 ahora
de este lado tenemos un carbono unido a
todo esto es un metano y tiene un
halógeno unido a él justo aquí que creen
que pasará bueno el avión hidróxido ya
dijimos que como tiene un electrón ext
eso le da la carga negativa así que si
tenemos un avión cargado negativamente
se sentirá atraído a cosas positivas
entonces en esta reacción nos referimos
a la unión hidróxido como el núcleo filo
qué significa amar así que esto es un
amante de núcleos le gusta compartir un
par de electrones de este lado tenemos
al bromo esta molécula es el bromo
metano el bromo es electro negativo en
realidad es más electro negativo que el
carbono entonces en este enlace tenemos
2 electrones y el bromo los atraerá con
más fuerza que el carbono los tendrá
cerca de él este enlace se romperá y el
par de electrones se irá junto con el
bromo
esto ocurre en un solo paso y es la
clave para poder nombrar a la reacción
como vimos hace un momento el núcleo
filo que tenemos aquí puede decir tengo
carga extra la puedo compartir con un
núcleo que en este caso es nuestro
carbono entonces el núcleo fi lo
compartirá este par de electrones
formará un enlace el carbono tendrá un
electrón y el oxígeno el otro electrón
ahora como el carbono estará
compartiendo la mitad de los electrones
con el oxígeno
entonces el bromo se quedará con todo
esto
siempre que vean este tipo de flechas
significa que hay movimiento de
electrones así que este par de
electrones se irá con el bromo y este
par será compartido con el carbono se
formará un nuevo enlace con el carbono
ya que sucedió esto y después de que la
reacción ocurre nos queda algo así
primero dibujar el bromo
ahora es una unión ya tenía 1 2 3 4 5 6
electrones y ahora tiene un par más que
halo de este enlace así que ahora tiene
una carga negativa el bromo es neutro
cuando tiene 7 electrones de valencia
pero como ahora tiene 8 electrones
entonces tiene una carga negativa ahora
dibujaré lo que ocurrió para todo esto
primero dibujaré al carbono y tenemos un
hidrógeno hacia nosotros trato de
mostrarles que este enlace sale de la
página así que tenemos este hidrógeno
que está hacia nosotros y por acá uno
queda lejos de nosotros
y finalmente tenemos uno hacia arriba
ahí está y ahora el avión hidróxido está
unido a este carbono entonces el grupo
hidróxido está justo aquí
dibujaré el enlace del color de estos
electrones
ahí está el oxígeno tiene dos pares de
electrones estos de aquí y está unido al
hidrógeno
qué fue lo que ocurrió el oxígeno ahora
es neutro ahora tiene 1 2 3 4 y luego la
mitad de este enlace es decir un
electrón y otro electrón de este enlace
en total tiene 6 electrones de valencia
lo que lo hace un oxígeno neutro
mientras que el bromo es ahora negativo
una forma de verlo es que la carga
negativa fue transferida al bromo en
esta reacción el bromo se va por eso se
le llama grupo saliente este es el grupo
saliente
otra cosa que quizá les parece
interesante es que cuando elaño en
hidróxido entra en acción se dice que
ataca al bromo metano y el bromo se va
entonces podríamos decir que tenemos dos
reactivos en esta reacción tenemos a la
unión hidróxido y allan nyom bromuro el
carbono con tres hidrógenos también
facilitó la reacción así este año un
ataque y el bromo se fue en este
contexto al carbono con sus tres
hidrógenos le podemos llamar sustrato
todo esto es el sustrato
y como le llamarían a esta reacción
bueno como hemos sustituido al bromo por
el hidróxido tiene sentido que sea una
reacción de sustitución ocurre una
sustitución
y con que se llevó a cabo bueno
sustituimos con un núcleo filo
núcleo filo y cuantos reactivos están
involucrados en la etapa determinante de
la velocidad de la reacción quizá no
tenga mucho sentido para ustedes pero en
realidad esto tiene una etapa
determinante esto quiere atacar al mismo
tiempo que esto se quiere ir
así es como ocurre la reacción entonces
para este caso tenemos dos reactivos que
determinan la velocidad de la reacción
en otros vídeos verán que sólo hay un
reactivo involucrado pero para este caso
tenemos lo voy a escribir
los reactivos
etapa
determinante
de la velocidad dos reactivos
involucrados en la etapa determinante de
la velocidad de la reacción y para
sintetizar todo esto simplemente decimos
que es una reacción s n 2 s n 2 una
sustitución con un núcleo filo y 2
reactivos involucrados en la etapa
determinante de la velocidad de la
reacción